buonasera a tutti chiaro che dopo
l'intervento di massimiliano io adesso
no grande e grosso mi sento un piccolo
piccolo però il titolo così del mio
intervento credo che
riflette esattamente poi buona parte di
quello che ha detto massimiliano perché
la capacità al all'adattamento diciamo
il cambiamento
spesso li abbiamo senza neanche
accorgercene ormai fa parte del nostro
del nostro vivere quotidiano se torniamo
in effetti indietro nel tempo anche
quando eravamo bambini
in effetti abbiamo subito dei
cambiamenti senza quasi neanche
accorgersene ecco quelli della mia età
ad esempio si ricordano benissimo che i
nostri giochi erano i giochi di strada
si passava più tempo in strada che a
casa oa scuola si giocano al pallone si
giocava con le carrette con la fionda
si viveva con la paghetta dei genitori
per comprare il gelato andare al cinema
quando si poteva si passavano i vestiti
e le scarpe tra fratelli
e però questo cos'ha significato ha
significato che poi nel tempo ognuno di
noi è cresciuto
ha accettato e si è adattato al
cambiamento perché se io in effetti
avessi dovuto crescere in base al tempo
che ho passato per strada sarebbe dovuto
diventare un piccolo delinquente invece
poi mi sono allineato e alla fine ho
fatto la strada che che molti come me
hanno fatto ecco se uno pensa a quello
che ero io a quell'epoca è con nessuno
ero bravo sia scuola però nessuno si
sarebbe immaginato che poi avessi potuto
fare la mia strada come molti in campo
finanziario aig un pò in giro per il
mondo perché questo è un po e un po la
mia la mia storia ecco quindi questo lo
dico perchè perchè credo che la prima
constatazione che ognuno di noi deve
fare e che
diciamo il cambiamento è un processo in
processo naturale e dobbiamo anche con
così prendere atto del fatto che spesso
e volentieri il nostro futuro dipende da
noi non dipende da altri no spesso e
volentieri siamo noi a scegliere il
ruolo che vogliamo giocare nella vita se
vogliamo essere protagonisti
ossia o se vogliamo essere comparse
quando parlo di queste cose mi viene
sempre in mente l'ho letto più volte il
libro di leonardo sciascia tanti di voi
avranno letto giorno della civetta dove
si fa esattamente riferimento al ruolo
dell'uomo nella società lo ricorderete
si parla di uomini mezzi uomini
ominicchi scusate ci sono anche
piglianculo e quaquaraquà ecco a questo
punto bisogna decidere da grandi un po
come cosa si vuole fare poi è evidente
che ci sono anche altri altri elementi
che di cui bisogna tener conto però
credo che quello sia il primo aspetto il
primo aspetto importante ecco fatto
questa premessa perché perché adesso vi
vorrei raccontare un po qualche fatto
del mio percorso professionale no per un
po associare quello che è stato il mio
percorso col titolo che ho voluto dalla
l'intervento di oggi no quindi camp armi
si nasce lottatori si diventa poi
nell'ultima parte invece mi soffermerò
sul fatto che l'importante cresce e
crederci a non mollare mai allora la
prima esperienza un po particolare l'ho
fatta nel 1980 c'era stato nell'ottobre
dell 80 al terremoto a napoli come
ricorderete io ero entrato in banca da
poco e quindi anziché fare lo sportello
come tanti miei colleghi aveva accettato
di andare con un gruppo di 100 persone
della mia banca l'allora san paolo a
napoli a gestire una rete di sportelli
nel circondario vesuviano che
chiaramente non solo viveva e il
problema del terremoto ma oltretutto
operava in un territorio non facile sia
dal punto di vista ambientale ma anche
un po stile dal punto di vista della
popolazione all'epoca perché erano
arrivati i piemontesi siano chi sono
questi cosa vogliono vogliono i nostri
soldi e quant'altro beh non vi nascondo
che quell esperienza per me è stata
utilissima e mi ha marcato proprio anche
nel corso della vita quindi la rifarei
domani ed era un qualcosa di nuovo che
mi sono scelto io non mi ha imposto non
mi ha imposto nessuno l'altra seconda
esperienza importante ve ne racconto
qualcuna che esulano dalle attività
tipica
bancaria che anche abbastanza noiosa
ecco la seconda esperienza l'ho fatta a
varsavia in polonia era appena caduto il
muro di berlino e quindi poi nel 90 la
banca mondiale voleva che i sistemi
bancari
dell'europa dell'est si aprissero
all'occidente e quindi con un gruppo di
persone auguro era un gruppo
internazionale avevo accettato di andare
per tre anni a varsavia a cercare di
impostare diciamo una delle banche
locali secondo criteri di tipo
occidentale bene non vi nascondo che in
quel periodo si toccava con mano ecco la
voglia della gente dopo la caduta del
muro di berlino di cambiare vita di
scappare di vedere qualcosa di nuovo
anche quella non è stata un'esperienza
facile assolutamente però di nuovo me lo
chiedessero oggi la rifarei subito di
corsa ecco è questo direi è un altro
passo importante
della mia vita il terzo aspetto
importante pochi anni dopo avevo 41 anni
mi hanno chiesto di andare a prendere la
responsabilità negli stati uniti nella
nostra filiale di new york e di tutta
l'america latina è un passato sette anni
è stato un'esperienza di vita che ho
vissuto ovviamente con mia moglie
ho passato parecchio tempo in america
latina perché in quel periodo poi
abbiamo anche aperto tutti gli uffici
messico argentina cile e brasile è di
nuovo non si trattava di andare in
brasile a copacabana ma si trattava di
andare ad aprile degli uffici di tipo
finanziario anche complicati ecco anche
quella di nuovo è stato un qualcosa che
nel più nessuno mi ha chiesto di fare ho
cercato di chiedere io di farla e per
fortuna
sono stato così è stata approvata la mia
richiesta perché volevo ero curioso
volevo capire volevo conoscere volevo
crescere è quindi anche qua di nuovo un
futuro ho cercato un po di costruirmelo
e non e non di subirlo ecco non ultimo
il fatto che ero a new york quando c'è
stata la disgrazia delle torri gemelle
quindi anche quello fa parte degli
aspetti negativi dei molti positivi che
ho vissuto
vi posso anche garantire che uno dice
sei stato sette anni a new york che
bello non sono tutte rose perché vivere
all'estero per sette anni non è come
andarci in vacanza si cambiano le
abitudini si cambiano gli amici bisogna
adattarsi agli usi e costumi del posto e
anche qui però torno a ripetere lo
rifarei non rifarei lo rifarei subito
ecco rientrato poi nel 2002 in italia
mi dietro la responsabilità di tutto gli
internazionali del nostro gruppo e lì
iniziò la campania cosiddetta
dell'europa dell'est perché in quel
periodo le banche italiane acquisivano
banche nell'europa dell'est perché lì si
era creato una nuova opportunità di
sviluppo per il nostro paese e quindi ho
passato diversi anni ad andare a cercare
di comprare cosa che poi avvenuta ma
anche in bosnia in croazia slovenia no
ogni volta che per cui stavamo una banca
diventava un po il presidente della
banca e quindi dovevo passare parecchio
tempo da quelle parti albania
ultima in ordine di tempo l'egitto è
anche quello non è stato bellissimo come
esperienza però piuttosto complicata
e anche lì per due anni ho passato più
tempo in egitto che forse è che forse in
italia però di nuovo la rifarei subito
ecco quindi in ultimo poi visto per non
farmi mancare niente c'è stata poi la
famosa fusione tra intesa e sanpaolo nel
2007 di nuovo quando si fondono due
banche simili si fondono anche i ruoli
si fanno le scelte delle persone e
quindi di nuovo da lì a dover fare a
farmi largo a gomitate per cercare di
mantenere certe posizioni e certi ruoli
ecco il racconto questo perché perché in
effetti come ho detto all'inizio ecco la
tenacia la voglia di fare la rabbia
interiore per chi torno a ripetere come
me non aveva santi in paradiso ma era
partito da zero come tanti altri e aveva
cercato di condizionare gli eventi
anziché di subirli alla fine della fiera
mi aveva dato quella spinta interiore
per cercare veramente di correre e
dovevo farlo più veloce degli altri ecco
quindi questo credo che sia
un'esperienza così di vita e
professionale che volevo condividere con
voi ma non perchè la mia è una storia a
parte particolare la mia attorno a
ripeterà una storia come tanti come me
si sono fatti largo a gomitate
cercando veramente di tirare fuori il
massimo che potevano avere che vuol dire
anche fare sacrifici vuol dire anche
mettersi sempre in gioco e questo credo
che sia un po un altro aspetto da
sottolineare ed è un po la sintesi del
mio titolo di oggi perché perché spesso
e volentieri gli altri molti guardano ti
ha avuto successo con nvidia non si
interessano per nulla della storia come
si è arrivati in certe posizioni ma solo
per principio non senza da parte loro
cercare di rischiare qualcosa criticano
pensando sempre che ci arrivi in certe
posizioni solo per grazia ricevuta ecco
non è così almeno il mio caso ma come il
mio molti altri conferma che non è stato
così io ho dovuto cercare di compensare
certo sì quando partiva un po indietro
rispetto agli altri e cercando di fare
qualcosa di più di diverso dando magari
più disponibilità facendo magari qualche
sacrificio in più però il destino ho
cercato di costruirmi lo da solo e non
che lomelo costruissero melo
costruissero altri dico questo perché in
conclusione ecco vorrei lasciare un
messaggio ai giovani e qui in sardegna
un messaggio di cui si è molto bisogno
che è il famoso messaggio della
meritocrazia
tutti sono convinti che la meritocrazia
non esista tutti sono convinti che si
arrivi solo in certe posizioni per
particolari spinti o quant'altro
certamente è vero che esistono anche
queste cose non bisogna negarlo però la
meritocrazia esiste è difficile da
fermare
ma esiste spetta ai cosiddetti decision
maker nel mio piccolo io sono uno dei
tanti come in questa sala cercare di
affermarla sempre ma soprattutto credo
che spetti ai giovani ecco cercare di
conquistarla sapendo che bisogna
conquistarla con fatica ma con la rabbia
interna la buona volontà si possono
arrivare così come ci sono arrivato io
ho cercato di essere molto sintetico
così lascia un po più di spazio a
qualcun altro magari vi ringrazio ai
buona serata a tutti
[Applauso]